you know I have to tell you I realized
yesterday that my my Jewish friends are
absolutely right absolutely right when
it comes to shellfish III had a fried
oyster for the first time and it's clear
to me that these vile creatures were not
meant for human consumption and that's
probably why God buried them at the
bottom of the sea I mean I think that
was probably a hint you've got these
you've got these mucousy slimy
gelatinous salty slugs covered in a hard
shell buried in the sand covered in
hundreds of feet of shark-infested
waters maybe that's a sign that we're
not supposed to be eating these things
and I really do wonder who was the first
person who dove to the bottom of the
ocean and found this brown rock and
brought it to the surface cracked it
open and saw all that salty snot and
said no maybe I'll maybe I'll try that
and then how did that ever catch on it
understand
now look cows and on the other hand cows
live on the land they're dumb they're
slow they're delicious
plus they come with their own beverage
so they come with a side beverage and in
the so it's like obviously God has
practically put a neon sign on cows
saying eat me but shellfish not so much
so I think I'm gonna go kosher kosher
except for the not eating bacon part I
still do that but the as far as
shellfish goes I'm on board all right
the the so-called migrants Caravan
containing about 7,000 or so Central
Americans is is is continuing its march
north the United States still still many
hundreds of miles away I don't think
there's any official demographic count
for the caravan but just looking at the
footage there appear to be quite a quite
a few grown men in the crowd this this
does not seem to be a caravan of women
and children despite how the media may
portray it this this would seem to be
predominantly a caravan of physically
capable adult males and that's the first
point I want to focus on here okay
these this is the kind of thing people
get a
offended or whatever when you say this
but the then people get offended by
everything so who cares these people are
leaving their homelands because their
homelands are dysfunctional and
destitute okay
but as much as and you see some of this
footage they're waving their national
flag their Flags of origin they're
waging waving as they march but they're
marching away from their country so so
how proud of your country can you really
be if you're abandoning it how patriotic
can you really be if you're leaving your
country and I think that's the a big
part of the problem and this is a part
of the discussion that people don't
really want to have but maybe these
maybe we should consider the possibility
that these countries are destitute and
dysfunctional because or in large part
because significantly because they're
physically capable adult males keep
leaving you know you you can't how are
you gonna have a country of your own if
all of your if all your guys keep
leaving you maybe if those men were to
stay behind in their own countries and
work to rebuild their country and
rebuild a way of life maybe then there
wouldn't be a reason to come here you
see it seems like the Pro illegal
immigration side they kind of lose
either way because you know we know they
got very upset when Trump infamously
said that these countries aren't sending
their best the other side says well yes
they are okay but either way it doesn't
work you see because if these aren't
their best if these really are criminals
and and and and so forth if these are
the the dregs of their society then
obviously we don't want them here but if
they are the best if they are
hardworking and competent and capable
people that's all the more reason for
them not to come here and stay and fight
for and rebuild their own countries we
don't want a country sending us their
worst but it's madness for a country to
send their best your worst you shouldn't
allowed to dump on another country your
best you shouldn't want to dump on
another country you know I made this
point yesterday and some some people
told me that well well the only reason
they're coming here is because we ruin
their country their countries are
destitute and dysfunctional because of
us it's our it's our fault our
government's policies cause these
problems now I think that's a weird kind
of paternalism here here again you see
this sort of white saviour bigotry
that's so common among among white
liberals you're said you're suggesting
that these people have no say over their
own lives that that the the fate of
their country has nothing to do with
them whatsoever they have no control no
say at all that's what you're saying you
you are relieving them of of blame which
is what you want to do but you're also
relieving them of agency your having
they if they have no agency over
themselves over their country's over
their lives it's it's all the fault of
the white man the white man in America
caused the problem and the white man in
America is the only one who can solve it
that's what you're saying I find that
extremely extraordinarily racist and and
besides even if that were true which it
isn't but even if it were true that this
is all America's fault we destroyed the
entire hemisphere all the countries we
destroyed it all well then that would
mean that these men are fleeing their
homelands and coming to the country that
destroyed their homeland I mean how do
you that's what you're saying you're
saying that we it's our fault we did
this we're the big bad evil villains and
so they're coming to us it wouldn't that
be an act of enormous cowardice in that
case I mean wouldn't that be traitorous
to your country if a foreign country
destroyed America and left a destitute
would you leave here and go to that
country that did this thing Oh
would you stay and fight for your home
now you know I don't think that the
United States is responsible for
destroying Central America though though
I agree that some of our policies
dealing with the war on drugs and the
cartels and so forth have been terrible
but to put the blame entirely on us is
simplistic and absurd and it doesn't
undermine the point that I'm making here
in fact it strengthens the point that
many of these bends should be staying in
their own countries either way no matter
how you slice it right I just think this
is a really important point to emphasize
because if we're looking for long-term
solutions to the immigration problem
well then I think those long-term
solutions have to involve these
countries keeping their own labor forces
rather than sending them all to us I
just think that if we're if we want if
you want these countries to get on their
own feet as it were then it has to
involve that second thing about this
anytime immigrations in the news you
always have people claiming that
Christians are compelled by the Bible by
Jesus by our teachings to support
unfettered emigration this is one of the
only subjects where the left suddenly
likes to talk about the Bible usually
they hate the Bible they hate
Christianity they think the Bible is a
book of fairytales but when it comes to
immigration and and you know a few other
issues like gun rights or you know the
welfare state then all all of a sudden
they're they're opening that book of
fairytales and insisting that clearly we
must we must hold their position if we
want to be Christian well that's that's
obviously not the case Christianity is
not a political platform it does not
give us policy proposals it's it's not
like the Republican or Democrat platform
where you can go and they've got a
position on every single you know social
cultural political issue that's not the
way Christianity works and in fact the
faith allows I think for quite a bit of
intellectual diversity it is if you like
an open-minded faith we're supposed to
be open-minded well Christianity is very
open-minded
now obviously the fundamental doctrines
of the faith are not negotiable we're
not open-minded about that
but as for political and cultural issues
all we can do is apply Christian
principles to the issue and see where it
lands us that's that's what we can do on
something like abortion or gay marriage
these principles will unavoidably land
us completely on one side every time so
if you're applying Christian principles
obviously you're going to be against
killing babies there's just no way to
get to the pro baby killing side if
you're starting with Christian
principles you just can't get there
if you want to get there you can have to
throw the Christian principles aside or
or it's not going to work but on issues
like immigration taxes gun rights
foreign policy economic policy health
care etc faithful and devout Christians
can come to a variety of different
conclusions
it's it's it's possible to you know hold
many different positions on those kinds
of issues on immigration as far as I can
see it the only completely unacceptable
view for Christians is the one that
supports all forms of illegal
immigration without restriction but the
one that says we'll open up the borders
let everyone in forget about the law
forget about borders forget about all
that that's not a Christian you know
that's that's not a Christian
perspective that's a that is a Marxist
utopian perspective a Christian with
that view is supporting criminality
illegalities he's undermining the
authority of the state an authority that
we're told he has given to the state by
God so that's not an acceptable view for
Christians but aside from that there is
a spectrum of positions a Christian can
hold one of those positions which
happens we mind mine is that rampant
immigration legal or illegal is bad for
almost everyone it's bad for America
it's bad for the countries that are
being abandoned as we've talked about
the only person who might benefit is the
individual immigrant but I don't think
it's it in this situation I don't think
it's ethical or moral moral or logical
or prudent to put one person on
pedestal above everyone else I don't
think you can put the interest of this
one person above everyone else above the
law itself I don't think we can do that
now clearly when you're weighing you
know the individual versus the
collective you're not always going to
come on the side of the collective if
this is a life or death issue if for
instance directly and intentionally
murdering an innocent person might
benefit the collective well then that
still is not okay it's not okay to
murder the person this is an argument
that people make for abortion all the
time they say well you know bees babies
are unwanted they're just gonna be poor
they're gonna end up in jail they're
gonna commit crimes it's already what
the world is overpopulated no it's not
that's a myth but the world's
overpopulated so for the for the sake of
the collective we should have abortion
well that is a morally unacceptable
position
we can't go kill an innocent person for
the sake of the collective but we're not
talking about murdering immigrants here
this is not life or death we're talking
about simply not allowing them to come
here and in that situation I do think we
have to weigh everyone's interests and
go with the strategy go with the policy
that benefits the most people I just
want to emphasize this for a moment a
moment because this is important the
options when it comes to immigration the
options are not let them in or kill them
okay
now the way people talk about this issue
you would think those are the options
like if you don't let them in then it
says then we're we are rejecting their
very lives this is you hear people say
that well if you're really pro-life you
would be Pro immigration what what does
that have to do with anything what does
pro-life have to do with this if the
other option was killing them then yes
this would be a pro-life issue but
that's not it we're simply saying that
we should enforce our laws and not let
them in they can go back and live in
their own countries they can go to any
country that will accept them this is
this is this is that's all as for us we
have laws we have a border and it should
be enforced there is nothing in the
pro-life
platform that should make us opposed to
law and order in fact we should be in
favor of law and order because all the
whole reason why we have laws and why we
have order is for the sake of us for the
sake of human beings because we
recognize that human life is sacred and
precious and so we need laws to protect
those lives and to establish order
siding with law and order on the
immigration debate is not the same as
siding against the very existence the
very lives of these people we are not
denying the sacredness the sanctity the
preciousness the value of their lives
when we simply say we have laws and
we're going to enforce them all right
one other thing I want to talk about on
a different note megyn kelly had a
conversation on her show yesterday where
they were talking about offensive
Halloween costumes and she remarked that
in her opinion she doesn't see why it's
offensive for a white person to dress as
a black person if the if they're
dressing as a black person they admire
in order to pay tribute and she gave the
example of a white woman dressing as
Diana Ross well of course this sparked
outrage and and people were offended in
hurt and traumatized and and they made
their tummies hurt that she would dare
to utter this opinion about costumes and
then later on in the day she issued an
apology I don't think she owed an
apology for two reasons number one and I
feel like a broken record here I'm
saying this all the time but I think I
just I feel like it needs to be said
over and over again that you cannot
ignore a person's intent when they say
something
so if somebody says something and you
know that their intent was perfectly
innocent that they were not trying to be
offensive they were not trying to say
anything hurtful if you know that then
there's no reason to be offended even if
what they said was clumsy inartful
whatever if you know that they weren't
trying
the offensive of you if you know what
they meant then there's no reason to be
offended and if you get offended
anyway it's because you wanted to be
offended it's because you are a cynical
opportunistic jerk looking for a reason
to be offended that is the only excuse
to be offended by something that's the
only reason why a person can be offended
by something that they know was not
intended to be offensive megyn kelly is
just another example you can disagree
with her position about costumes
whatever she clearly was not trying to
be racist that she did not consider this
to be a racist comment there was no
racism underneath it so if you say well
I know you didn't mean it as racist but
I'm gonna take it as racist well then
you are a liar and a fraud if that's
what you do well I know you didn't mean
it that way but this is how I'm gonna
take it well you know what then you
should apologize to her if you're doing
that you should be the one apologizing
in fact you should you should be she
should be saying you're welcome because
because you should be thanking her you
know when you get offended by something
because you wanted to be offended then
you should be saying thank you to
whoever offended you because you wanted
to be offended you were desperate to be
offended you wanted nothing more than to
be offended you're so excited to be
offended so you should say thank you to
the person who offended you you were
obviously looking for an excuse you got
it well say thank you be polite where
are your manners
I just I hate this so much I mean of all
the things in modern society that I
can't say this might be the thing this
might be above everything else this
propensity that people have to get to be
offended to choose to be offended when
they know that the intent behind the
remark or the comment or the action was
totally innocent and we act like intent
is irrelevant it's not irrelevant intent
is the whole point that's all that
really matters in communication all that
matters is what do I mean when I say it
and if you know what I mean then that's
then that should be it we can't have
communication I think we all all human
communication
breaks down this way if you are if you
are going to refuse to receive what a
person tells you in the spirit and with
the intent that they clearly meant it
now um on the issue of on the issue of
Halloween costumes in general look I
don't dress in costumes myself I don't
find it especially appealing to dress in
a costume I haven't had the desire to
dress in a costume since I was about
five years old but I do know that the
point of Halloween costumes is to have
fun
most costumes are in good fun I think
you rarely see a mean-spirited costume
every once in a while you do okay so you
see some idiot dressed in every you know
you'll see you see stories of some [ __ ]
dressed in a in a holocaust costume or
something well that obviously is
mean-spirited that's not in good fun
you're not you're not having good fun
with the murder of six million people
but most costumes aren't like that most
costumes are even if they're tacky even
if they're outrageous even if they're
inappropriate they're still not
mean-spirited so um should a white
person be able to dress as someone of a
different race or of a different culture
uh of course they should obviously I
mean don't be ridiculous why are we even
talking about this clearly they can
clearly there's nothing wrong with it
now I know that when I say they can I
know that if they do they're gonna be
you know people won't tolerate it in in
this irrational age that we're living in
but in an ideal situation if everyone
was rational and we were all mature
adults there would be nothing wrong with
it if it's if it's meant in good fun if
it's meant to be a tribute if you just
happened there's nothing wrong it's it's
you're just like non Irish people on st.
Patrick's Day they'll dress in in really
ridiculous exaggerated Irish themed
costumes
I mean people dress as leprechauns for
goodness sakes people dress as
leprechauns to this and by the way
st. Patrick's Day is a is a is a is a a
religious holiday on top of that so
you're coming in on this religious
holiday and making a mockery of the
Irish dressing as a leprechaun well you
know what no Irish person gets offended
by that I think that actual Irish people
in Ireland I've never heard of any of
them being offended I think they just
laugh about it and they roll their eyes
and they kind of laugh at us people of
Irish descent in America we don't start
crying about it we're not offended we
laugh we have a good time in fact we're
we're flattered on st. Patrick's Day
everybody wants to pretend that they
have Irish ancestry and so those of us
who do we feel kind of you know we feel
kind of good about ourselves we feel
kind of kind of cool then everybody
everybody wishes they had the same
ancestry that we do so you should be
flattered by that so it's the same thing
with Native Americans I mean for you
know a lot of white people and look at
Elizabeth Warren she's not the only one
a lot of white people in America wish
that they had Native American ancestry
even if they don't and so if they dress
up as a Native American they're paying
tribute this is meant to be flattering
you should be flattered by it it's you
know for whatever reason they're like
there are two things it seems that every
white person in America wants to be they
want to be Irish and they also want to
be Native American okay
so whatever there's no reason to be
offended by that you could laugh at it
you could say that's silly it is but why
be offended and and and look it's not
like I know I know you might say well
well it's different because black people
Native Americans they've been oppressed
they've been persecuted this is a this
is a persecuted group of people so to
dress up as them as well I don't deny
that they've been oppressed and
persecuted but but what do you think the
Irish haven't have you read it do you
know anything about Ireland are you
kidding me
I the Irish people have not been some
dominant powerful force in the world
we're talking about a culture that has
suffered terribly been persecuted
terribly in their own country and and in
the United States it's been it's been
the
the history of the Irish people has been
misery after misery yet yet they take
this all in stride so you know what and
it on st. Patrick's Day nobody is
talking about the plight of the Irish
people no one's having this conversation
nobody's wondering whether or not Irish
people are offended by this
nobody does so you know what I have no
interest in double standards I just
don't if it's okay to dress Irish if
it's okay for non-white people to dress
as white people at Halloween
then white folks can dress in whatever
costume they want I'm sorry
the double standard is not working for
me I'm not gonna go along with it I
don't think anyone should if you have a
double standard then why should why
should I care what your opinion is if
you clearly have a double standard why
should I respect that if you're gonna go
and celebrate st. Patrick's Day and get
drunk in your leprechaun costume making
a mockery of the Irish you know
associating them only with leprechauns
and being drunk if you're gonna do that
don't pretend you're a fool that well
that that data costume offends my
cultural heritage well you can't do that
what why should I take that seriously
and by the way I also don't agree that
the offended person is always right and
should always get his way well if
someone's offended by that costume
that's reason enough not to wear it no
it's not it's not any reason enough
because people get offended by
everything so it's not reason enough to
stop doing something well if someone's
offended you shouldn't do it you
shouldn't say well that means I'm not
gonna do or say anything ever again
because somebody's always offended
maybe the offended person should stop
looking for a reason to be offended
maybe the offended person should say to
themselves oh it's just a costume on
Halloween it doesn't matter it's just
someone is just having fun maybe I'll
just be cool about it for once in my
life and calm down and just let people
have fun without looking for a reason to
rain all over the parade
maybe we should expect the offended
person to do that you know what about
that
in the case of an intentionally
mean-spirited costume well that's
different but even then if it's
intentionally mean-spirited it means
that the person's pitiful and they're
and they're looking they're desperate
for attention so the last thing you
should do is give them attention just
ignore them but if it's meant as a
tribute if it's in good fun if it's if
it's the same jokey kind of spirit as
the st. Patrick's Day stuff then well
maybe you should just laugh and move on
with your life just the thought alright
we'll leave it there but as I said I
don't dress in any costumes for
Halloween but I don't begrudge those who
do have a great day everyone I'll talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed